what's christmas for you connor what
dream
like where what's your christmas what's
your christmas
from my christmas yes yeah come on what
what's what's this what is your
christmas
christmas is not spending the whole day
with his fans i like spending the day
with my family is chris is like a
special day for you not not like does it
mean some of you but like it's
you you know you know what i mean
where's just like is christmas just like
the day i'm indifferent towards i don't
feel anything particular on the day yeah
i like spending it's a good i like the
idea of spending time with the family
you know i feel like [ __ ] it's not a
monk zuckerberg right now don't i
i like human activities i like seeing
people on the day of the 25th
i'm cooking a skillet
barbecue sweet barbecue race
sorry
you know i to me it's like
it's i don't know it's i like watching
the christmas movies they're fun i like
i like the jingle all the way that's my
favorite one jingle all the way what's
that one where uh arnold schwarzenegger
tries to buy that uh figure for his kid
oh that one i didn't know the name of
that one yeah
that movie is so good that's my favorite
christmas movie um yeah i i don't know
it's uh i like christmas eve a lot as
well actually with the family because
everyone's kind of like everyone's
starting to warm up everyone's uh kind
of like getting uh yeah getting that
family vibe this way because christmas
eve for us is a normal day
i don't know we don't do anything
special because every night we kind of
like all kind of like talk you know
watch tv or yeah drink you know have a
nice meeting we don't talk otherwise
pretty much
not as like a collective family unit
right yeah yeah i'll talk to my mum and
dad or then i'll go somewhere and then
my brother will you know what i mean
like he's never like the whole units
together yeah yeah
even now because you know all me and my
family all of us live in uh
me and my brothers all live in different
areas
my brother's gonna go to canada now as
well oh [ __ ] so it's gonna be even
harder to get everyone in the same place
i i was the difficult one because i was
on the other side of the world but now
everyone's gonna be the difficult one
yeah yeah so i hope hopefully i'll get
to see because i didn't get to see my uh
my older brother when i went back to the
uk
because he was busy doing stuff in
scotland i think or something are you
going back this year
what the christmas this year no no i'm
not okay i i don't want to deal with
travel again
um
i feel that i lost enough of my lifetime
one but because you didn't go to america
to see sydney's family right yeah so i
guess that's fair enough i i don't have
anything like that so i i saw my family
they got to see me i'll see you next
year
i'll probably go back at some point in
april or something and see them again
wait was it your parents that said that
they would probably never come to japan
no
why is that no no no no they they never
said that oh
well
yeah well why not next time you know
when the country opens up they come here
oh yeah maybe that too because i don't
think they haven't come to japan before
either no no my parents really want to
come to you yeah as well i bought yeah
my christmas present was flights for
them like last year oh
do christmas presents roll over
i'm like what oh yeah you haven't
redeemed it yet so oh my oh man it's
sitting there waiting
yeah i know they want to they really
really want to they've i've really sold
them on the idea when i first moved here
they weren't too hyped on it but yeah
after they've watched after i moved here
they kind of watched a lot more stuff
about it and they're really excited to
go yeah which is great because i can't
wait to see how utterly confused they
are
um
but yeah i'm really excited to come over
and yeah that'll be fun when the last
time you did spend christmas with your
family then well it must have been a
while right uh the one before japan so
2000 right 2019 i was in japan right yes
2018 christmas then damn damn i spent a
long time
i guess so yeah that's three years right
yeah
uh yeah three yeah three years ago
because the first the first christmas i
just moved to japan in october and i was
kind of settling in yeah so i was like i
won't come back i'll come back next year
next christmas
that didn't happen and then i didn't
come about this christmas either did you
guys ever cook for christmas or who does
the cooking for christmas oh my dad my
dad yeah because because it's like
spends like 12 hours the day before
that's my that's just like two days so
like what i've always wondered is when
does the torch get passed over right
because when you have your own kid's gun
yeah because you have no choice
hopefully not for a while because uh i
need a lot of catching up to do
because yeah i mean um yeah i've started
cooking my own roast as well and i'm
just like i kind of like how my roast
cooked but i don't think it's as good as
my mom's yet but i'm just like i'm i'm
gunning for it eventually but also
for the title also i don't know when in
my life i want to like spend my entire
day cooking because when you cook a
christmas dinner you're just like as a
kid
as a kid you have comfort in knowing
that's like that's like the parents job
to like deal with you know you're out
here having fun with your family they're
out there just cooking and all that [ __ ]
for an entire day and i'm just like when
is that gonna be my job i'm kind of
dreading that when uh when a little baby
man is appears in your life i guess
that's that's when you can start joe
don't lie you're just gonna make aki do
it you're gonna be like honey honey well
i mean
well you know every thanksgiving she she
you know spends like an entire day
cooking food and i'm just like oh [ __ ]
that
i'm not doing that are you kidding me
you get to enjoy the fruits yeah exactly
i get to just enjoy the food right so
yeah i don't know like i've been
thinking that too because like because
like every time because i i guarantee
when i go back for christmas yeah uh
which i will be by the time this comes
out um my dad is gonna force me and be
like son
it's time you learned the way no no no
no no no he's gonna he's gonna he's
you're gonna be in the other room he's
gonna email you do your show
he's gonna leave a youtube comment
dear son come here make my last video
hey son help me with the roast
[Laughter]
yeah but like you know every time i do
go back home and he because he cooks
every night um right i i do you gotta
learn the family recipe right yeah right
like i've learned some of you what's
your dad's like specialty my dad's
specialty uh my dad's specialty is
moroccan chicken wow yeah
so he he bought like this like proper
like moroccan uh like uh pot type of
thing that has like the kind of funnel
lid
on it uh which is like apparently what
they use in morocco please correct me if
i'm wrong about that but um yeah it's
like spice moroccan chicken with dates
and lemons and yeah it's so good yeah
i'm definitely gonna make get him to
make that when i go back home but it
also takes like six hours to make and
i'm like
i mean i love to have that
yeah every week in my house but i also
don't wanna invest in a [ __ ] pot let
alone spend six hours cooking this thing
you know well that just means you
haven't reached that point in life yeah
i know when you said i don't want that
in a house you're just like maybe uh
maybe have some spare time to uh start a
hobby maybe i should uh yeah you know
because there there are some like
kitchenware which you never use apart
from like that one event in the year
right yeah you know when you're like a
teenager when you're like a teenager
you're just like why would i need this
thing this is just taking up space right
i hardly have any space in my kitchen as
it is but you know now especially moving
into my new house i'm just like i
remember going to connor's house and i'm
just like oh connor this this cutlery it
feels good it feels good connor god damn
this isn't this isn't dyso cutlery
i bought
i did actually feel a little bit like
when i helped uh aki last year for
thanksgiving and she she made like a
turkey
like a whole turkey thing because we
bought an oven finally and uh you know
the gratifying feeling of me going honey
bring out the oven tray
it was just like oh this is a special
day
we never bring this thing out oh my god
oh it's a special event
so i'm i am going to be like that i'm
already like that with like tools
you know because i i've i've you know
slowly which what kind of tools like
like diy like you know like oh okay okay
like hammers and like all that kind of
[ __ ] right because i still don't own a
hammer yeah
not in japan wait what i don't own a
hammer hammers are quite useful yeah
they are quite useful a mallet maybe
like a rubber mallet this is like pretty
good
rubber mallet yeah yeah but you need it
you never you never know you never know
when you when you need it you're like
thank god for [ __ ] yeah whenever you
needed one in japan like having to like
knock some screws out of place or
something or nail nail some things down
to like prop maybe an artwork up or
something or you know whatever the ikea
table was being annoying with the screw
i needed a hammer like push it in making
like like tables and stuff like that you
just like kind of knock it in it's
coming a lot more i can't tell you every
use of ad fit but i remember i've had
multiple times i've been like thank god
i finally bought a hammer yeah now that
because like when we the our current
place that we're in because we have two
balconies right and like building those
balconies i was like oh i am missing
like 90 percent of essential tools so i
just went out a day to like tokyo hands
or whatever and just like binged like
blind binge binge boy
i just i just like splooshed on all
these tools it doesn't binge anime
anymore binges ninjas binges hardware
and like not gonna lie that was probably
one of the most fun shopping experiences
i've had
uh
i sure do oh my god
where can you use a power drill in japan
many places because like because because
after a while because like especially
when you're buying furniture like when
you first make so when i was first
building my my room i i was like okay i
have a much bigger room now i'm just
gonna replace all of like the desks and
like shelves and everything with like
much bigger nicer places that fit the
atmosphere right so obviously when you
buy stuff from like ikea or amazon or
whatever they don't come in one piece
you gotta [ __ ] diy that [ __ ] right
yeah i've i've definitely been feeling
that for like the past
past few years don't you hate it
twisting the [ __ ] screwdriver for 17
hours in the week
and to the point where your wrists and
your thumb starts to get sore i do
regret it i guess yeah
so when i bought like my new bookshelf i
i still had the screw right and i was
like oh good this book shelf has 50
screws that i have to screw in and
they're hard as [ __ ] as well but by the
time i finish like three hours later my
hands were so sore so i was like [ __ ]
i'm buying a power drill because though
i had another shelf coming in built that
[ __ ] in like 30 minutes because all i
had to do was go
and i was like
this is technology is amazing it's
incredible remember when ikea selling
point was like that you get to build
your own furniture and it's like all
convenient and stuff yeah and now i'm
just like i've ordered some furniture
furniture off amazon which doesn't need
to be built and i'm just like this is a
[ __ ] godsend
they're ahead of the game man
some ikea products i'm i think you can
pay them to assemble in your house yeah
you can you can because sometimes ikea
furniture is actually like really good
yeah because they have some things no
ikea has great furniture it's just you
know like paying the ass to me yeah like
like especially moving into a new place
you know making making one or two things
that ain't too bad that's that's a fun
that's a fun afternoon when you're
making like 10 [ __ ] things in a day
you're just like can this thing just
come pre-built and there are some like
there are some ikea things where like
even the way that you have to build it
is like some kind of artistic feat where
it's like [ __ ] algebra one to get
like a [ __ ] piece in because it just
looks so weird on the instruction thing
my table kind of broke a little bit and
one of the screws is missing
exactly it happens one of one of the
biggest things one of the biggest things
that annoys me is that i've i've now
that i've built so much furniture in the
past few weeks i i know what kind of
packaging is just like good and
optimized and what is awful right so
like i was building i was building a
shelf yesterday and like every single
screw every single compartment every
single plank had like a number sticker
on it or like came in came in came in a
bag that was labeled as a certain number
yeah and that's great because you look
at the instruction manuals and you see
ah this number of screw goes into this
number plank yeah yeah i [ __ ] hate
the
the the furniture that gives you a bag
of screws and then you get the
instruction manuals and it gives you
like ten different kind of screws and it
doesn't tell you which one is the same
they all look the same
it [ __ ] like blows my mind feeling
trying to like
it's so [ __ ] hard trying to
differentiate like a screw that's this
length and a screw that's this length on
the instruction manual and i just like
that could be one of ten screws which
screw am i supposed to use now the one i
hate more than that is like when it
tells you like okay you have this many
screws right yeah you should have ten
screws and so i go to count and i'm like
why is there 11 screws
that's not the screw then i realize one
is just there for a spare right but they
don't tell you it's a spare so you just
have to assume that one of them is a
spare so it's like okay because when you
finish building it and then you realize
and you look down and there's like three
screws left over you're like yeah well i
clearly [ __ ] up somewhere some
sometimes in japan they they give you a
pair of gloves with your furniture yeah
oh yeah yeah because for some reason you
need like they it's like to not hurt
your hands i guess when you build it
they give you like a pair of white
gloves it's really yeah i don't know
it's cute yeah it's really cute i never
wear them because i'm like what the [ __ ]
would i wear gloves
but i actually i don't like they give
you these shitty screwdrivers and like
allen keys oh yeah it's such a waste
yeah i buy like eight things and i have
eight [ __ ] screwdrivers that i have to
get rid of i i have a cupboard of just
the shirts unused allen keys
like the the shitty screwdrivers are
less common than the allen keys yeah
well i bought my own set of allen keys
yeah same thing all like perfectly
measured yeah and they're great really
good quality and it's so much better
than using these tiny ones where you
like destroy your palm trying to do that
last turn
they clearly don't understand the
concept of torque yeah
they're not long
and like the quality of for some reason
there are some furniture that the
quality of the screws it's just like all
over the place [ __ ] there's some that
are just like perfectly ingrained you
can get your skull drivers steel
enhanced nails and then there are some
which i swear like pre-sheared so you so
like you turn it it's like a [ __ ] it's
like a [ __ ] ice skate right it's just
slipping in and out and i'm just like
how am i supposed to get this career the
worst feeling is when you like go for
that like it's like it's like this much
of the screw is still out and you turn
it and you feel it's sheer yeah and you
look at it and it's like already sheared
you're like
it makes like that horrible like
you have to like fully like put your
full pressure on it yeah not stop
because if you let go it will shear it
more yeah yeah yeah you're like [ __ ]
i've got to get this in before before
i'm [ __ ] up
is everyone keeping up
you know what we're talking about right
just furniture things
just middle-aged guy things